yeah sexy yeah yeah your nose is out of
control
your nose dude it's like I can't even
deal with it because even when I was
performing and I saw him up there
we you know literally I was eight
minutes in you've just been staying I
know but I was like on stage and my side
that was my tip that was the tip of your
nose right here my side angle is not
good it's nice
but noses like yours are all the rage
with with Jews really yeah
it's all the race for the Jews oh yeah I
get like tagged in tick tocks and like
men or like girls who like guys with
bigger nose of like I've never met a
girl who'd been like your nostrils yeah
it's correct not your nostrils it's
because when you go down on us and
especially from behind the tip of your
nose touches the ass and it really
tickles it
what I have a built-in vibrator you do
you have a built-in second appendage
that tickles ever so slightly the tip of
our [__] and it feels so good I've
been with a guy whose nose was massive
and I can tell you confidently that I
think about him to this day solely
because of the the ass to nose touching
like how big was his nose like like a
Nigel Thornberry type of guy or whatever
I mean like it was the first thing you
saw in a room he was a really big guy so
it matched his whole look but it was
Adrian Brody knows oh yeah
but his isn't area embroidery it's not
but it was such an [__] yeah they can
touch their [__] back of her spine
no you're like a Lincoln Memorial no
like an a like you're part of a
Lincoln's like face club or whatever you
know I mean
you just have one of those like
I live in the woods who else is in that
Facebook no I don't have that at all you
teach your face not your body okay okay
your body's no no your body's like um
well another two things all right a lot
of Jews sorry sorry my bad my bad are
you Jewish come on okay yeah my bad yeah
my mom is my dad's not all right good
yeah I love him
my parents are the Jews the Jews in
general okay I love them good they got
great noses beautiful ones so I don't
know if you saw the article he pulled up
but it said there's a correlation to
better Dick and bigger nose I'd rather
have John's I'd rather have better
ingredients I'd rather have no dick and
not your nose this is also interesting
well they said you could have yours I'd
rather have not to [__] know Bobby
we've seen your penis it's
essentially the same five reasons why
men with big noses make the best
husbands also the the guy in the picture
has the tiniest no he also has a man bun
so I think they should pick the wrong
guy in general so Trevor does any of
this apply to you oh man with big noses
have more muscle I mean we'll ask the
audience here dude oh that's pretty good
oh I didn't know I don't know what's up
no Bobby number two they're thought to
be wise and powerful and I can see that
Bradley Cooper agent Marley
uh they have better luck with money
nobody driving
come on I mean maybe I mean is it I
don't know is it the nose or the people
that's a real question with the money
part uh we'll go with this oh number
five they have a crazy libido I have a
libido what is that you like [__] oh
yeah I'm down I thought
yeah I got it I thought libido I thought
Libya was that game where they put the
stick and you have to go underneath it
what's that
yeah but I could do that too with my
nose I could eat out oh yeah yeah just
go right under it right yeah but you
wouldn't be good at that game what
eating ass or no lambido
[Laughter]
but your nose would tip it I feel like
you'd be really good at libido oh I'd be
great at let me I feel like you can get
real low I get so low definitely you can
get under a Ford F1 I don't have to do a
fan I could just walk across yeah
how tall are you oh are you gonna go
reverse now no you're gonna attack me
now probably yeah yeah all right I would
never the other night of improv you were
so funny in watching you go up it's one
of my favorites because you're before
you go on you're quiet you're kind of
sitting there and then you hit the stage
and it just pops and everybody like not
one person in the room is not watching
like everybody's locked in on you except
for me I was looking at the that's
something else but no you weren't I
could see you up there I was up there
you're up there and I was doing this
with my hands yeah my precious my
precious but no you did great no you
listen bud can I call you bud please I
um I honestly think that um
you're moving up in the world thank you
and I you know when I look at you and I
and I'm with you I feel like we've known
each other forever in the business and I
feel like you're a part of the crew I
know I was excited to get the call to
come back round two yeah everyone comes
back to this really yeah I was gonna say
people somebody must have canceled today
did somebody cancel today oh Adrian
wrote it that's the name no no one
canceled no I got the text I'm like [__]
yeah dude what'd you get when you when
you get taxed about 20 minutes ago no
one no when was he booked no I think a
couple days ago yeah yeah I heard your
name on the list yeah yeah